[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis einen schönen guten
abend und willkommen den sport hat
norbert lehmann für sie ein stück von
mir neue maßnahmen gegen korona das
bestimmende thema heute
ringen um coroner regeln kanzlerin
merkel und die länderchefs beschließen
neue grenzwerte für einschränkungen der
bundestag verabschiedet das
infektionsschutzgesetz
kliniken am limit weil in immer mehr
krankenhäuser die intensivbetten knapp
werden müssen rettungsdienste weite
umwege fahren
und krise in belarus hunderte
flüchtlinge die an der grenze zu polen
ausgeharrt hatten werden in den irak
zurück geflogen
es sind gerade entscheidende tage was
neue corona maßnahmen in deutschland
angeht am mittag hat der bundestag ein
neues infektionsschutzgesetz beschlossen
alles wichtige dazu gleich erst einmal
schauen wir auf das treffen der
ministerpräsidentinnen und präsidenten
mit der kanzlerin dort wurde bis gerade
eben um eine gemeinsame linie gerungen
klaus brodbeck mit den ergebnissen
der aufmarsch fast schon wie beim duell
erst bund kanzleramtschef helge braun
dann länder spd regiert michael müller
berlin
unions regiert hendrik wüst enervie dann
wieder der bund und gerade in vielen
rollen olaf scholz die ausgangslage nach
tagelangem streit sagen wir durchaus
unübersichtlich
mehr als vier stunden geht das ringen
klar ist anschließend es ist es bleibt
ernst
wir wissen und das ist bedauerlich wir
könnten besser dastehen denn die
impflücken nicht so groß wäre und
deshalb werden viele maßnahmen die jetzt
ergriffen werden müssen nicht notwendig
gewesen denn der mehr geimpfte menschen
hätten und es ist nie zu spät sich
impfen zu lassen wir setzen jetzt
bundesweit ab eine hospitalisierung rate
von 3 im freizeitbereich auf zweige
regeln bei einem wert von 6 auf 2 g +
regeln unter einem wert von 9 in
abstimmung mit den landtagen so sieht es
das infektionsschutzgesetz dann ja vor
auch auf weitere maßnahmen auch am
arbeitsplatz brauchen wir mit der 3g
regel ein deutlich höheres schutzniveau
das gleiche gilt für den öpnv einen
regional und fernverkehr alle regeln
sollen im dezember überprüft werden
einigkeit besteht im frust über die im
fluge wir haben wie es eben geschildert
wurde heute miteinander beschlossen die
angebote deutlich auszubauen die
impfzentren die impfstellen es wird
weiter die mobilen teams gehen
selbstverständlich
wir werden weiter und personal werben um
noch schneller auch die
auffrischungsimpfung anbieten zu können
alles richtig aber genauso richtig ist
es jetzt auch deutlich zu machen dass es
nicht ewig so weitergehen kann dass eine
minderheit eine mehrheit dominiert und
deren gesundheit gefährdet mein appell
ist dass alle sich jetzt ein ruck geben
und die entscheidung für sich selber
ihre liebsten für ihre angehörigen
treffen und es ist gut dass wir deshalb
eine solche ausweitung der angebote
bekommen für jedes impfangebot aber gilt
es muss auch angenommen werden das
problem bleibt
fragen wir nach bei theo koll theo
welches signal wollen bund und länder
jetzt mit diesen beschlüssen senden also
auf jeden fall ein ganz klares
warnsignal die kanzlerin hat es
dramatisch formuliert sie sagte es ist
eine hoch dramatische lage also das war
glaube ich ein ganz wesentliches signal
und lange überfällig das zweite wichtige
sind dieser neuen schwellenwerte man hat
jetzt die hospitalisierung rate hat man
eingeteilt in verschiedene kategorien
das heißt wenn innerhalb von sieben
tagen von 100.000 einwohnern drei
menschen mit corona ins krankenhaus
kommen dann gilt flächendeckend zweig
das heißt also zugang zur veranstaltung
nur noch für geimpfte und genießen wenn
der wert auf 6 geht und wir sind
bundesweit fast dabei dann gilt zweig
plus das heißt dann müssen auch die
genesenen und geimpften sogar noch einen
frischen test haben um zugang zu
bekommen
und wenn der wert noch höher geht was in
zwei bundesländern fast erreicht es dann
gibt es kontakt einschränkung und alle
möglichkeiten die das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz bietet haben sie
auch gerade gehört dieser maßnahme
sollen dann auch überprüft werden im
dezember soll es eine evaluierung geben
was bedeutet das ich glaube das ist ein
ganz wichtiger hebel der einigung die
die zusage von olaf scholz der dann
möglicherweise schon bundeskanzler ist
ist man wird am 9 dezember oder
spätestens am 19 dezember das ist die
nächste ministerpräsidenten konferenz
wird man die maßnahmen die man jetzt ins
infektionsschutzgesetz geschrieben hat
überprüfen haben die funktioniert
reichen sie aus also ich glaube dass man
damit den kritischen
ministerpräsidenten die andere maßnahmen
wollten entgegen gekommen ist und gesagt
hat wir versuchen um es mal flapsig zu
formulieren die kuh vom eis zu bekommen
diese politische differenz und wir
werden schauen ob das wirklich so
funktioniert wie wir uns das vorgestellt
haben danke schon mal für den moment wir
sprechen uns dann gleich nochmal
vor dem bund länder treffen wurde heute
im bundestag das neue
infektionsschutzgesetz der geplanten
ampel koalition beschlossen allerdings
nur mit der mehrheit der fraktion von
spd grünen und fdp union und fdp
stimmten dagegen die linke enthielt sich
vor der abstimmung gab es eine hitzige
debatte bevor wir darauf schauen und
blicken wir aber erst einmal auf die
korona maßnahmen die durch das gesetz
gelten sollen ina kurschilgen
neu eingeführt werden soll die 3g regel
am arbeitsplatz wer hier mit menschen in
berührung kommt muss geimpft oder
genesen sein oder dem arbeitgeber
künftig einen negativen corona test
vorlegen jeden tag und der arbeitgeber
darf nun seine mitarbeiter nach ihrem
impfstatus fragen und diesen
dokumentieren außerdem soll es womöglich
wieder home office geben die dreijährige
gilt auch im nah und fernverkehr sowie
bei innerdeutschen flügen ausgenommen
sind schülerinnen und schüler ein
weiterer punkt beschäftigte und besucher
von pflegeheimen kliniken oder
gesundheitseinrichtungen sollen künftig
nur noch mit tagesaktuellem negativen
test zutritt erhalten
bundesländer die besonders stark von der
korona pandemie betroffen sind können
noch weitere maßnahmen ergreifen
beispielsweise zweig plus regeln
einführen das heißt dann dürfen nur
geimpfte oder genesene plus zusätzlichem
test teilnehmen auch kontakt
beschränkungen und das verbot von
freizeitveranstaltungen können verhängt
werden ein soll aber definitiv nicht
mehr möglich sein nämlich bundesweite
schließungen und verbote das heißt
ausgangssperren flächendeckende
schulschließungen verbote von reisen
oder hotelübernachtungen und auch nicht
beispielsweise die gastronomie oder den
einzelhandel komplett dichtmachen all
das wäre mit diesem gesetz
ausgeschlossen
unzufrieden mit dem neuen gesetz ist ja
die union sie kritisiert das auslaufen
der epidemischen notlage und droht durch
die unions-ministerpräsidenten das
gesetz im bundesrat zu blockieren wo es
morgen zur abstimmung steht heike
slansky über die bundestagsdebatte
es war schwer heute zueinander zu finden
die partner von einst in zwietracht
jetzt ampel gegen union notlage ja oder
nein das alte oder das neue
maßnahmenpaket eine hitzige debatte im
hohen haus gelände haben mit dem
vorgelegten gesetzentwurf mehr
möglichkeiten des effizienten anders als
bei der aktuell noch gültigen rechtslage
2d 3d 3d plus kontakt beschränkungen im
öffentlichen und privaten bereich
personen obergrenzen wir hätten diesen
gesetzentwurf auch zugestimmt heute wenn
sie gleichzeitig die epidemische lage
nationaler tragweite verlängert hätten
denn beides ist notwendig was tun gegen
die davon galoppierenden
infektionszahlen die ampel parteien
hatten in windeseile nach heftiger
kritik nachgebessert und trotzdem reicht
es der union nicht aus die fdp fragt
wollen sie verfassungswidrige
ausgangssperren helge braun sagt nein
wollen sie den handel den einzelhandel
pauschal schließen armin laschet hat
gestern beim handelsverband deutschland
erklärt der handel ist kein pandemie
treiber und recht hat er damit
pauschale schließungen gibt das ampel
gesetz nicht mehr her differenzierte
schon allerdings mit der zustimmung des
jeweiligen landes parlaments was
machen wir eine scheindebatte und sie
können nicht beantworten welchen
maßnahmen erforderlich halten die hier
nicht drinsteht streuen sie den menschen
hier nicht sand in die augen sie
verringern hier den instrumentenkasten
und setzen damit die gesundheit der
menschen auf das spiel nur eine partei
hält von der ganzen corona politik
nichts die ampel partei machen
anscheinend mit japanischen politik der
letzten zwei jahre nahtlos weiter und
herr linder sie haben ja sogar gestern
eine impfpflicht nicht mehr
ausgeschlossen und da sieht man
eigentlich sind noch nicht wann der
regierung und schon das erste mal
umgekippt die erste wichtige namentliche
abstimmung die die ampel parteien für
sich entschieden haben die union droht
nun mit blockade im bundesrat die linke
empört jetzt diese geisterfahrerei wir
blockieren das im bundesrat das ist
unverantwortlich eine rechtssichere
grundlage für den schutz der bevölkerung
des dringend notwendig der kleinen
schritte während im land das virus tobt
morgen ist der bundesrat am zug ausgang
offen
scharfe debatte also im bundestag theo
koll die union hatte mit einer blockade
des gesetzes morgen im bundestag gedroht
das scheint jetzt aber vom tisch zu sein
richtig
also das ist noch nicht ganz sicher
politisch würde ich sagen ja mit dieser
überprüfung mit der evaluierung bis zum
9 dezember glaube ich sieht es danach
aus dass man dort ein kompromiss findet
aber das muss morgen jedes einzelne land
auch noch für sich entscheiden und dann
entsprechend im bundesrat abstimmen im
prinzip hat die union zehn von 16
bundesländer beteiligungen in den
regierungs es heißt sie könnte morgen im
bundesrat das ganze stocken das hätte
aber die konsequenz dass ab kommenden
donnerstag wir keine gesetzliche
grundlage mehr hätten zur bekämpfung der
pandemie denn dann läuft die epidemische
notlage automatisch aus sie soll ja
nicht verlängert werden und die gesetzes
mechanismen die wir brauchen
vermittlungsausschuss um das ganze dann
noch zu lösen bis donnerstag die glaube
ich sind also der vermittlungsausschuss
ist noch gar nicht eingesetzt und das
würde alles länger dauern als wir noch
zeit haben theo koll vielen dank für
diese einschätzung
und im anschluss an diese sendung haben
wir auch ein zdf spezial für sie zu den
wichtigsten entscheidungen heute was
genau wurde im bundestag beschlossen
beispielsweise zu 3g am arbeitsplatz und
wir haben die abgeordneten darüber
abgestimmt das alles finden sie online
und auf unserer zdf heute
der präsident des robert koch-instituts
lothar wieler hat ein dramatisches bild
der korona lage gezeichnet er sagte
wörtlich wir laufen momentan in eine
ernste notlage und wir werden wirklich
ein sehr schlimmes weihnachtsfest haben
wenn wir jetzt nicht gegensteuern
er forderte erneute kontakt
beschränkungen und eine höhere impfquote
bei einer online-diskussion mit der
sächsischen landesregierung
schauen wir auf die aktuellen zahlen des
robert koch instituts mehr als 65.000
neue fälle wurden binnen eines tages
registriert
264 menschen starben im zusammenhang mit
kobe 19 die inzidenz steigt weiter auf
aktuell 3
136,9 erstmals seit einem monat wurden
gestern wieder mehr als 500.000
impfdosen verabreicht
die ständige impfkommission stiko
empfiehlt jetzt allen menschen ab 18
jahren eine auffrischungsimpfung diese
sollen der regel im abstand von sechs
monaten zur letzten impfdosis der
grundimmunisierung erfolgen so die stiko
eine verkürzung auf fünf monate können
im einzelfall oder bei ausreichenden
kapazitäten in betracht gezogen werden
viele krankenhäuser sind mit ihren
intensivstation am limit besonders in
den belasteten regionen geplante
operation wenn abgesagt notfälle wie
herzinfarkte oder schlaganfälle können
immer öfter nicht schnell versorgt
werden eine herausforderung für den
rettungsdienst die mühsame suche nach
einem krankenhaus hat jutta sonne wald
in der nähe von münchen begleitet diese
88 jährige ist mit einem
kreislaufkollaps zusammengebrochen der
erste einsatz an diesem tag für martin
moss und sein team vom brk
rettungsdienst in dachau nach haus nicht
aufnahmebereit für uns also die haben
keine kapazität
so fahren jetzt nach münchen 20 bis 30
minuten umweg mit einem schwerkranken
patienten an bord das ist zurzeit für
die rettungsdienste alltag die
intensivstationen und notaufnahmen sind
überlastet die einsatzkräfte müssen
notfallpatienten teilweise stundenlang
in weit entfernte kliniken
transportieren oder weniger bis gar
keine ruhepausen zwischen den einsätzen
das war mal zehn minuten runter fahren
kann weil man ebenso lange unterwegs ist
und wenn man dann mal wieder zurück ist
eine eigenheit stellen gebet dann geht
sofort den nächsten einsatz weiterer ist
es schlag auf schlag zu den möglichen
einsätzen kommen derzeit viele corona
transporte diese sind in den vergangenen
vier monaten in bayern um das vierfache
gestiegen die rettungsdienste sind am
limit ich glaub mal dass es für die
angehörigen patienten noch viel
frustrierender ist weil wir stehen ja
für schnelle hilfe die können wir
aktuell iphone nicht mehr so leisten
unterwegs verschärft sich die lage der
88 jährige patientin nach münchen
transportiert werden soll erleidet einen
herzstillstand und musste reanimiert
werden er braucht sofort
intensivmedizinische behandlung daher
die entscheidung doch in die klinik nach
dachau zwangs belegung mit jeder neuen
lieferung verschärfen wir die lage in
den kliniken die müssen schauen dass die
ressourcen frei schaufeln für die
patienten und ich hoffe dass noch die
grund dinge die grundversorgung einfach
gut steht der älterer patient braucht
einen herzschrittmacher doch seine
versorgung ist nun kritisch denn
aufgrund der rasant steigenden zahl der
korona intensivpatienten müssen die
krankenhäuser in fünf der sieben
bayerischen regierungsbezirke jetzt alle
nicht akuten operationen verschieben
und auch bei unseren nachbarn in
österreich steigen die ansteckungszahlen
mit krone auf immer neue höchstwerte
deshalb beraten auch dort bund und
länder über schärfere corona maßnahmen
die bundesländer salzburg und
oberösterreich fordern einen
mehrwöchigen lockte nicht nur für
ungeimpfte sondern für alle sollte
dieser nicht landesweit kommen wollen
sie im alleingang handeln ganzer
scheinberg hat einen locker und für
geimpfte vehement ausgeschlossen
und soeben wird noch gemeldet das
parlament in wien hat den weg für die
weitere strafverfolgung gegen ex kanzler
sebastian kurz frei gemacht der
nationalrat das parlament hob einstimmig
seine immunität auf der
svp-fraktionschef war nach vorwürfen der
untreue bestechung und bestechlichkeit
als regierungschef zurückgetreten
und wir schauen an die bälle russisch
polnische grenze von dort sind heute
hunderte flüchtlinge in den irak zurück
geflogen es könnten noch mehr
zurückgeschickt werden so der
belarussische machthaber lukaschenko
unter der bedingung dass deutschland
etwa 2000 menschen aufnimmt
bundesinnenminister seehofer weist das
zurück er ist heute in polen um die
regierung dort in ihrer harten haltung
an der grenze zu unterstützen
christiansen fast den tag zusammen
es ist das ende einer odyssee das ende
ihrer hoffnung irgendwie nach europa zu
kommen für rund 400 menschen ging es
heute vom flughafen in minsk zurück in
den irak ein letztes elfi vor dem
sonderflug nach bagdad mit zwischenstopp
in erbil
einige meiner freunde und ich gehen
zurück das wetter war sehr schlecht und
es war sehr kalt
noch immer sitzen tausende menschen in
belarus fest weil diktator lukaschenko
und schlepper sie mit falschen
versprechungen hierher gelockt haben um
polen zu unterstützen kam heute der
deutsche innenminister nach warschau
seehofer widersprach meldungen aus
belarus deutschland würde 2000
flüchtlinge aufnehmen ich habe sofort
mit der bundeskanzlerin kontakt
aufgenommen
und die
klare auskunft erhalten dass es hier um
die falschmeldung geht und noch jemand
wiederholte heute seine unterstützung
aber für lukaschenko wladimir putin
steht weiter eng an seiner seite in
moskau gibt putin erneut dem westen die
schuld an der krise
wir kommen nicht umhin festzustellen
dass die westlichen länder die
flüchtlingskrise an der bieler russisch
polnischen grenze nutzen um neue
spannungen in einer für uns nahen region
hervor zu rufen um druck auf minsk
auszuüben
am abend kamen die ersten irakischen
flüchtlinge in erbil an auf sie wartet
in der heimat eine ungewisse zukunft
in einem bußgottesdienst im kölner dom
hat das bistum köln das versagen der
kirche bei der sexualisierten gewalt
durch geistliche bekannt in dem
gottesdienst sagte der apostolische
administrator rolf steinhäuser von
priestern und weiteren kirchlichen
mitarbeitern des bistums seien eine
große zahl von verbrechen sexualisierter
gewalt an schutzbefohlenen verübt worden
dabei bischof vertritt kardinal rainer
maria woelki der sich nach schweren
vorwürfen im umgang mit der aufarbeitung
der fälle in einer mehrmonatigen auszeit
befindet
und wir schauen noch kurz nach kanada
dort gilt in der provinz british
columbia nur der notstand sintflutartige
regenfälle haben im westen des landes
übers wochenende zu heftigen
überschwemmungen geführt premierminister
turbo hat das militär in die region
geschickt
17.000 menschen wurden in sicherheit
gebracht nach erdrutschen gibt es eine
tote und mehrere vermisste bereits im
sommer herrscht oder provinz nach einer
hitzewelle den notstand
und wir kommen zu deutschlands besten
spielers wäre von der war bei den ecken
hainholz inventuren jagd nach einem
souveränen 6 2 6 4 sieg gegen den polen
robert hoch katsch damit steht der
olympiasieger im halbfinale des turniers
der besten tennisspieler des jahres und
trifft auf keinen geringeren als den
weltranglisten-ersten novak djokovic
seinen geplanten urlaub auf den
malediven wird alexander zverev gerne um
ein paar tage verschieben denn in turin
winkt ihm großes einem klaren
zweisatzsieg gegen den
weltranglisten-neunten den polen hubert
uhr kath hier vorne im bild stellt
zverev unter beweis dass er auch gegen
einen starken surfern pauli spieler die
richtigen mittel findet coach ihm einen
wimbledon halbfinalist liegt schon nach
zehn minuten mit 0 4 zurück und steht
der dominanz des deutschen meist hilflos
gegenüber in zwei glatten sätzen macht
sich zverev auf den weg ins halbfinale
gegen den weltranglisten ersten novak
djokovic
das nach dem umkämpften spielen der
beiden in diesem jahr brisanter kaum
sein könnte
und beste tennis spielerin des jahres
darf sich gar in jerusalem als erste
spanierin hat sie die wta finals
gewonnen die 28 jährige bezwang im
finale im mexikanischen guadalajara die
es den annett konter welt in zwei sätzen
ja und die fußballerinnen des fc bayern
haben sich für die champions league
niederlage vor einer woche bei peek lyon
revanchiert die münchnerinnen erkämpften
sich im rückspiel gestern abend daheim
ein knappes aber verdientes 1 zu 0 so
ein sieg so scheint es ist irgendwie
immer noch die süßeste belohnung doch es
war ein harter kampf für die deutschen
meisterinnen aus münchen gegen lyon
gefährliche torraumszenen in der ersten
halbzeit auf beiden seiten mangelware
stattdessen nur leichte
annäherungsversuche in richtung tor nach
dem seitenwechsel agierten die
gastgeberinnen entschlossener das wurde
belohnt 69 minute sakiko maguy mit dem
kopf der führungstreffer in den
schlussminuten der rekordmeister aus
lyon bissiger barrieren musste zittern
doch es blieb beim 1 0 damit der fc
bayern weiter auf kurs richtung
viertelfinale
das war es um sport dankeschön ordnet
für viele bleibt es auch morgen beim
trüben himmel aber es gibt auch ein paar
sonnenfenster schönes wort wo erfahren
sie gleich von katja horneffer claus
kleber hat für sie das heute journal
heute schon um 21 uhr 40 und hier geht
es jetzt gleich weiter mit dem zdf
spezial zur corona krise morgen begrüßt
sie an dieser stelle mit resi riehen ihr
sagen auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend ein hoch auf die
skandinavien thies denn die bringen ein
bisschen bewegung ins wetter so wird der
hochnebel schon mal weg geräumt und
heute gab es häufiger mal einen sonnige
lücke zum beispiel im osten deutschlands
vor allen dingen heute morgen dann aber
auch hier im westen und im süden ist zog
allerdings auch regen auf und der
breitet sich jetzt langsam weiter in
richtung südosten aus und beschäftigt
uns auch noch in der nacht dann
erreichte nämlich hier die lausitz an
der ostsee bleibt es beim starken bis
stürmischen westwind sonst ist es häufig
bedeckt ab und zu fällt etwas
nieselregen und an den alpen wird es
klar deswegen sinken dort die
temperaturen auf bis minus 3 grad sonst
sind es in süddeutschland plus 5 bis
minus ein grad im norden bleibt es bei
etwa 11 bis 6 grad bilder und dieses
temperaturgefälle sehen wir auch morgen
über tag in norddeutschland sind das
also vergleichsweise milde werte
zwischen 10 und 13 grad im süden bleibt
es meist bei einstelligen 5 bis 9 grad
und auch morgen wird wieder für viele
ein sehr trüber tag an der ostsee bleibt
zu einem starken bis stürmischen
westwind und an der nordsee kann sich
auch mal kurz die sonne zeigen am
alpenrand aber scheint die sonne
strahlend an diesem wetter erinnert sich
am samstag wenig ab sonntag aber wird es
deutlich kälter schönen abend noch